the Joe Rogan experience yeah but they
don't want you to like what they don't
like which is you know it's thought
bubbles you know that's what it is it's
like people love when you are we people
love when you're predictable right it's
one of the reasons why people love when
people dress up in suits you dress like
a suit in a suit in you act like a
businessperson you you say words that
are you know you you speak in a very
very similar way to the other people
that you work with and it makes it easy
to map out what you're probably gonna do
and how you're gonna react there's a
very narrow band that you're operating
in when you're wearing a suit in the tie
and you're in office there's a narrow
band you could be the [ __ ]
suit and tie guy or you can be the
standard you know work language human
being gentleman you know that that kind
of stuff is that's people like that
because they know that they can kind of
predict you they know where you know
where you're going from but when you're
eccentric and when you're outside the
box you're unpredictable and you have an
eclectic taste they don't like it you
have interesting ideas that are
completely irreverent and don't fit into
these patterns like what is what is she
up to what the [ __ ] going on in her
head she out there watching wrestling
Pro Wrestling she actually likes it no
it's not yeah it's Pro fake wrestling
entertainment entertainment yeah but
some people don't like when you're
unpredictable and they'd also don't like
their own ideas being challenged it's a
lot of things that I think that people
love about other people that are deeply
religious if if they if you're deeply
religious and they're deeply religious
they know that they can talk to you in a
certain way well the Lord has a way of
making things work out yes it does Tom
yes it does and they know that you're
gonna fit yeah amen you're gonna think
in this narrow bandwidth you're not
gonna get outside that box you're you're
good Christian well I know Mike and
Mike's a good Christian you know and all
that stuff I hear about him just doesn't
make any sense to me it's a good control
mechanism yeah it's easy to hurt people
who you know like exist within this
narrow band well that's why politicians
almost always adopt some form of
religious ideology even Trump Trump was
basically never religious isn't
life never and I always got religious
that lady Paula white or something what
are the [ __ ] crazy but that lady is
amazing like for she's so crazy that
it's WWE that's what it is
I mean Trump used to be in the WWE I
know I totally remember this lady is
basically like a whacky manager
she's like a whacky manager in the WWE
that talks to God and helps Trump out
that's how I looked at it I'm like this
is his wacky manager he's got a
character now I'm sure he's got the
[ __ ] crazy hair he's got the spray
tan it doesn't go all the way to the
outside edges and he's got this wacky
lady who I don't want to say he's
banging her but I wouldn't be shocked
hmm no I become hot she hide a dirty old
crazy religious lady way I am dirty
Melfi religious lady oh this is fairly
pretty isn't she
not bad-looking listen I like her yeah
the way she presents but she's got the
Karen hairstyle which is not checked the
Karen hairstyle oh look at that look at
him he's not even he's deeply insult no
it's so obvious it's fake humbling you
don't know he might be a changed man
yeah someone's always wondered you know
I think that's the thing that kind of
ties all the threads of my life it's
just that I definitely oppose you know
go back to that picture please you know
who I believe in that picture
no that's not the picture you [ __ ] me
Jamie the picture that we were just
looking at it doesn't matter see that
lady in the the leopard skin
I believe her face she's barely into
this dots she's like what am i doing
what is this nonsense and Trump is like
I can't believe I'm president i won I'm
gonna win again I'll have to do is
listen this crazy lady talked to me
about Jesus so people got to buy into it
he's it's a great move you know I mean
he didn't go secular at all right but if
you look at his past in his history you
look he's not a religious guy and all
sudden he is and nobody even questions
it it's just lip service though he's in
the WWE
she's his manager yeah Lackey manager I
think I think Obama was similar III
think it was performative its
church-going I don't think they get down
I guarantee you they go back they do
outer altogether they listen to a CD
scene they [ __ ] like rabbits
[Applause]